even though I will tell you if you're in
this room you're one of the luckiest
point 1 percent of the people on the
face of this planet right and hey you
may have to spend the next 40 years of
your life to become one of the luckiest
point-o 1% of the people on this planet
but don't forget that you're luckier
than 99.9% of everyone who lives right
so why are we striving so hard why don't
we just make a difference to the world
without really being grumpy about it why
why is it that we I'm talking too much
why why is it that we are so unable to
enjoy the blessings that we've been
given when it is abundant to the point
that it is almost impossible to count I
would urge you to do that exercise yeah
I would urge you to count the number of
blessings that you have that a person in
Syria today does not have have yeah it
will blow you away
I mean I sometimes have people
complaining about their life and I would
say okay I want you to do me a favor I
want you to wait until January and then
walk the streets of Prayer in San
Francisco or New York find the homeless
person and complain about what you just
told me about yes if you find it in your
heart to do that to to repeat one of
those you know modern world problems to
them then it's a real problem I
frequently spend time thinking about
what it's like to live in the shoes of
people that are much less fortunate than
I am and I think that helps a lot with
having gratitude for the circumstances
that I do live in and this is all
different types of experiments
everything from what would it be like to
not have electricity what would it be
like to not have clean water or a
shelter over your head or constant
warfare going around or around you and
that when we really immerse ourselves in
those life experiences I think it
changes us for the better makes us more
grateful for what we do have
you touched on the importance of just
having an ice-cream and really enjoying
it and being in the park and just really
enjoying it rather than treating it like
an algorithm of needing to take your
kids to the park and just be frown but
rather go and run and play and take a
frisbee and dance and and when you're
walking on the streets
do your best to smile and you'll change
the way that other people's days are
going by doing something as simple as
just smiling on the street